now the destructive democrat agenda is
failing on all fronts and nowhere is it
more apparent than in our democrat-run
far-left cities for example
out in california homicides jumped 31
percent last year
in san francisco a new survey finds that
the city is on track to lose nearly half
its residents
in the years to come and in minneapolis
get this a judge has ordered the city
to hire more police officers after a
ruling in favor of a group that sued the
city council
over surging crime and perhaps the most
tragic of all is in chicago
where weekend after weekend dozens upon
dozens are
shot over 1500 so far this year
but failed mayor lori lightfoot she's
still refusing to take
any responsibility for her far-left
failings and is blaming it all on get
this
racism and sexism mayor in recent months
uh there have been questions raised
about your
your temperament and your reaction to
criticism
tribune editorial use the term irascible
how much of this do you think might have
to do with the fact that you're a woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it
women and people of color are always
held to a different standard
i understand that i've known that my
whole life
shameful that's absolutely shameful so
ask yourself
how is it the same people who claim to
care about lives in our urban areas
are the same ones fueling policies that
make the quality of life worse and worse
defunding police never ending attacks on
law enforcement
far left socialism government dependency
all while taking
no responsibility for the human
suffering in the human toll the loss of
life
and the loss of human dignity taking
place on their watch
month after month week after week and
day after day quite frankly
it is disgraceful the democratic party
the far left washington machine
and their allies in the media they are
leaving these communities behind
how often do you hear the names of the
victims of shootings
in those cities why aren't there
protests for those lives and why aren't
there massive fundraising campaigns
for those families because it's
democrats
they really don't care at all they love
having the issue
they love stoking the division they love
raising the money
but they never actually want to find a
solution
and the worst part it's all by design
because they are frauds they are
grifters and they
couldn't be less interested in
delivering real results for poor
and working americans all across the
country now
joining me for reaction civil rights
attorney leo terrell
and outnumbered co-host emily campagno
this has to be emily one of the more
shocking things you know i want women to
be in office i want all kinds of people
to have uh
you know experience in governing cities
and this is what tribal politics does
then destroying a city and then she
blames racism and sexism
what are your thoughts on that i agree
with you and it's also disingenuous
she campaigned over two years ago on
diminishing the quote unyielding
violence in the communities of chicago
she knew exactly what she was getting
into only to see it spike by 50 percent
her second year the homicides
and then for example after memorial day
weekend last month when there were 49
shootings and homicides she came out and
said this is a bloodbath and it's
unacceptable
only now in the face of criticism
rightly so and the public outcry she
calls it all of a sudden racist and
sexist when she herself came out from
the beginning to say she would do
something about it
we all know from her internal emails
that she's some type of maniac running
the office too so it's also disingenuous
for her to say that criticism of the how
she runs this toxic office
is anything less than everything flowing
from her but she is letting down the
community
to your point tammy and to the loss of
lives of for example
this past weekend a one month old it
just it's heartbreaking
and it is horrific leo you know we've
got a dynamic here where
we we claim and we we know that people
of color
women men everybody uh can be as great
as
a counterpart or as bad we know this for
a fact
and yet here she is right she ran as a
reformer shockingly
uh as emily as a really laid out and the
lives that are being lost
truly are our people of color are
brown and black communities being
destroyed and she seems to just
be fine with that how is this possible
well just look at this table look at
this panel right here
diversity women black she tries to speak
tammy
for all of us which i reject she said
women and people of color
are treated at a different standard
that's a lie she's trying to
hide and conceal her incompetence by
saying that blacks
and women are at a disadvantage that's
not true i don't see a disadvantage to
you tammy or emily
it's a lie it's a cover-up and what's so
sad about it is
she claims she plays the race card and
she's in charge of the system
and you're right people of color are
being killed
and yet the attention to it is being
disregarded an
oakland mayor tammy oakland police chief
was begging
the oakland city council don't cut the
funds i need the money
they cut it anyway democrats don't care
about people of color
they use them as pawns and yet their
lives are worthless and that's what you
see in chicago and in all these
democratic cities
it is shameful tammy yeah if the the
oakland example is perfect incredibly
eloquent plea from that man
about what mattered in a community and
yet this is what
tribalism does this is what identity
politics does emily
and it's being used now against the very
people
that have been trained into believing
that that was going to be their
salvation to
to obscure the death and destruction if
that's even possible
i this is and look we have to let's
admit it i it's clear i think in
people's lives
there is a different life experience for
black men
there's a different life experience for
gay people
for women who are perceived to be women
of color there is a difference
but if we make excuses and then allow
politicians to ruin our lives and then
to blame something else when it's their
incompetence
we're not going to make any headway
emily on any of these issues
that's exactly right and there in
oakland which is the city i was born in
the police chief called it a crisis
the same word used by the lieutenant
mayor and the police chief in seattle
where i currently live they said it was
a public crisis there the thinning the
eroding of the police ranks
the the unilateral defunding of the
budget we saw as well the judge that's
in charge of the consent decree between
the department of justice and the police
department there
said it took them two steps back he said
what were you thinking
doing this unilaterally you have set
back meaningful criminal justice reform
he said
by doing this we saw the same thing in
portland a unilateral defunding of the
police
the mayor begged to refund some of the
funds and the city council wouldn't even
hear
at the hearing the topic on the floor
they had to restore funds instead to
park rangers
to community volunteers and you can
guess how that went
the people who are suffering the most
are these communities of color we know
this in chicago
73 of those homicides are young black
men
as well it's the youth suffering you
know i a great point and and leo
you know we we've we're talking tonight
about what can people do locally we've
seen them go to the school board
meetings
but when we talk about as emily noted
about about the city councils
you've got people have got to start
going to the city council to be heard
because i think a lot of these local
entities
don't have not necessarily heard from
their citizens
i think you're absolutely right tim
we've got to start small with these
small
city council school boards and take over
these
democratic cities which have been in
control for over 50 years and you see
the destruction and the the poverty in
these democratic cities we got to start
small and work our way up
and and when i agree with your previous
panel we got to take over in 2022
on a national level it has to be all of
this it's not a zero-sum game
it's everything on this fourth of july
weekend
reassert that we are the sovereign we
must begin to act
within the structure of what the
founders expected
which was involvement at the local level
and of course
then the translation of that at the
federal one emily and leo thank you very
much now
coming hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else